welcome to this video playing eel a bib
I am yeah who's Arabian flex this Egypt
it is Egypt all right so while guessing
the flag I'm in a Queen's Indian what
what line now let's let's play Knight to
c3 most one of the natural developing
news this is some a system that is quite
often associated with Casper rose he has
played this line numerous times at first
in Assam large championship matches
against capital from the ages but he
always had this in his repertoire he
mostly played 63 though 92 ISM later
refinement that he also played the ideas
to delay to delay III because in some
cases you were unable to play a 3d form
in one go this is one of those where
this is may be possible depends what
yeah after this I'm going to I'm going
to play f3e for the six some rather
passive way to play this and now i'm
getting a quite comfortable version of
the damage
let's see what what black is doing I
very much prefer white here Black is
basically um yeah I don't like this move
in general I don't like it in the sender
structure it it it has the idea to gain
space and play on the King side but
ultimately it just weekends are 5 g
three controls fo and I'm doing that f12
III and controlling f5 sometimes this is
a welded way to play but I'm not sure I
mean for black but I'm not sure that
this is one of those times okay h form
you might play each form night have one
H 493 he takes g3 this is a bit but
uncomfortable okay on on h4 I probably
need to play rook to e1
I Bishop e3 was also interesting it
doesn't going to fit well with the night
everyone should be three it still would
have been interesting yes I thought here
at the end I'm going to get the play on
the fr okay so I need to need to get i
get all pieces involved wait I can just
take g4 I can just take this took me
quite a while yeah I know it's ugly but
if 95 I can I have five next and this
just as a dominating position for the
night it's very hard for him not to take
it at some point yeah I could have
played this much quicker it's so quite
obvious that this is good for white 95
queena 395 Bishop e3 g5 or night f5
Bishop e3 rook a2f to something like
that yeah this is a good idea actually
trying to get the Knight to g5 if I play
page one
Knight g4 a play rook age five just
being just being annoying
night if five or not yeah I can I can
play that
the only thing that irritates me is rook
age 5 gh5 Bishop f5 ye F&E form it's
probably not not really good but this
irritates me
mmm YUM
the seafoam woof
is there some way to to get the smooth
out of the picture
I wonder Q&A for or something
there's also a fine thing
yeah I probably shouldn't have allowed
that
quite unnecessary maybe root page five
wasn't really to the point
my deaf 5 and 10 to 24 but i'm not sure
that this really is good yeah maybe it
is check yeah while I have completely
completely misplayed this
the only good thing is that he's very
much down on the clock
maybe maybe still okay for me even but
why did I allow that still we should be
for him
he's down on 1991 hundreds jess second
time warning black forfeits on time chan
this is probably probably lost isn't it
III is made young what the heck did I do
wrong there just feel if this is just a
win here with good play rock age five is
probably just a fancy milk that's doing
nothing yeah this is much this is much
better just connecting pieces and then
putting it on aisle five just like that
yeah yeah this is this is much much
stronger this keeps control over the
position this is absolutely no
compensation now and now I'm getting to
that Bishop e3 and maybe then look age 5
or trading and queen h 1 h 5 I need to
break this blockade iam yeah this is
this is much better this is this is not
not yet a problem but this is this is a
problem I saw this hard too late yeah I
don't have the good solution anymore
really spoiled that down here black is
better what a shame
so I need to do something else in May
Queen eat you will yeah this is also
still okay intending long castle amazing
alright thanks for watching